as the supreme court appears poised to
overturn roe v wade treasury secretary
janet yellen testified to the senate
that restricting access to abortion
would have very damaging effects on the
economy yellen's key argument is that
access to abortion allows more women to
participate in the workforce and get an
education which increases their earning
potential
for example after abortion restrictions
were lifted following roe v wade in 1973
black women's participation in the labor
force increased by 6.9 percentage points
however among white women it only
increased by two points
yellen also noted abortion access helps
keep more people out of poverty and in
need of public assistance
a decade-long study known as the
turnaway study tracked 1 000 women some
of whom obtained abortions and some were
turned away from getting one
the study found the ones who were denied
were more likely to experience household
poverty
be unable to cover basic living expenses
have a lower credit score
more debt
and more exposure to the possibility of
bankruptcy and eviction
all of this also impacts the economy as
a whole
state level abortion restrictions cost
state economies a combined 105 billion
dollars per year
due to reduced labor force participation
and earning levels as well as more time
off and turnover republican senator tim
scott of south carolina hit back at
yelen's comments as harsh and unusually
piercing adding i think framing abortion
in the context of labor force
participation just feels callous to me
the senator argued more focus should be
placed on child tax credits child
infrastructure
and other measures to support families
if roe v wade is overturned it could
lead to 26 states banning abortion
according to the pro-choice guttmacher
institute
texas now bans all abortions after six
weeks of pregnancy
and florida and arizona have enacted
their own 15-week bans in advance of the
court's filing
in oklahoma house lawmakers gave final
approval to a bill banning abortion on
may 19th the bill bans abortions
starting from the moment of
fertilization
exceptions can be made for medical
emergencies rape incest or sexual
assault but only if those incidents have
been reported to law enforcement
the ban would be enforced through
private citizens lawsuits
the bill will now go to republican
governor kevin stitt who opposes
abortion rights and is expected to sign
it into law which would make it the
strictest measures against the procedure
in the u.s